au restaurant universitaire mont musard
seuls les premiers arrivés sont sûrs
d'être servis avant leur prochain cours
à 11 heures des dizaines d'étudiants
prévoyant patientes déjà devant la porte
ici les tarifs sont imbattables
pour 3 euros 30 pour moi de prendre les
repas à 1 € étant donné que je suis
boursière ici que de faire à manger chez
moi et faire les courses quand on arrive
à 13h il y a plus rien quasiment il y a
plus de dessert plus rien du tout depuis
la rentrée la fréquentation de ce
restaurant du crousabondit de 25%, 3300
repas le midi mille repas le soir la
situation devient intenable
je ne fais pas le choix de louper des
cours j'essaie de m'organiser pour ne
pas en louper et pour manger le plus
rapidement possible mais c'est vrai que
quand il a là il est 11h30 ça a toujours
pas ouvert la queue elle est elle est
déjà pratiquement pleine et donc là dans
20 minutes et c'est le zoo on vous
invite si vous voulez bien à signer la
pétition dénonçant l'inaction des
pouvoirs publics locaux et nationaux les
jeunes socialistes ont lancé une
pétition
le CROUS n'a pas prévu de structures de
restauration suffisante pour pouvoir
accepter le nombre d'étudiants qui est
en train de monter d'année en année on
veut qu'il y a un nouveau restaurant
universitaire sur le campus pour que les
étudiants puissent manger de façon digne
un équipement indispensable alors que le
nombre d'étudiants est passé de 23000 à
30000 en disant et que le restaurant
universitaire marais au centre de Dijon
à fermer ses portes il y a 8 ans nous
sommes là actuellement dans une
situation précaire avec un déficit
structurel de plusieurs millions d'euros
en vous imaginons on nous demande de
faire un effort de monter des structures
mais nous ne pouvons pas on a besoin de
financement c'est les politiques qui
peuvent nous aider ce jeudi les
étudiants risquent de trouver
porte-close de nombreux salariés du
CROUS seront en grève